les films sont des rêves
que l'on oublie jamais
[Musique]
Sami
tout paraît différent avec ses lumières
je ne retrouve pas la maison
c'est celle qui est toute noir où il y a
pas de guirlandes
dans cette famille c'est les
scientifiques contre les artistes
et dans mon équipe il tient de moi
[Musique]
on va faire quoi comme film
tu dépressies tout ce qu'il fait d'un
peu léger ou imaginatif
tu pourrais être un peu plus
encourageant
ce qu'elle a dans le coeur tu l'as aussi
il ne suffit pas d'aimer quelque chose
il faut aussi en prendre soin c'est plus
important que ton hobby arrête d'appeler
ça un hobby
maman a pris un singe mais pourquoi tu
as pris un singe parce que j'avais
besoin de rire
il faut toujours que tu monopolises
l'attention
de respect je suis quand même ta mère
la famille là
ça va te déchirer en deux
[Musique]
tu arrêtes de faire des films ta mère
sera un consolable je suis perdu je sais
plus quoi faire fais ce que ton cœur te
donne
est-ce que tu as préféré
[Musique]